la séance est reprise
madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président donc nous avons
reçu beaucoup de sous amendements
la commission déclare y recevable
en application de l'article 44 bis
alinéa 3 du règlement les sous
amendements qui ne se rapportent pas au
texte
et qui ne s'impute pas donc correctement
et qui aurait pour effet de contredire
le sens des amendements de l'amendement
auquel il s'applique
si
c'est très clair soit ça n'est pas dans
le texte mais un sous amendement qui
contredit le sens de l'amendement du
rapporteur n'est pas recevable
non je le fais pas la Loue c'est très
simple quand on a sous amendement qui va
qui va quand on a sous un amendement qui
va dans un sens contraire de
l'amendement et bien il n'est pas
recevable par ailleurs par ailleurs on
se calme par ailleurs
on se calme par ailleurs la Commission
des beaux yeux une exception d'y
recevabilité à l'encontre de tous les
sous amendements contraires aux
principes constitutionnels d'égalité en
ce qu'ils instaure des dérogations par
profession par pathologie ou par des
catégories de la population
et la commission prononcerait la même
exception du recevabilité
à tous les amendements similaires si
nous il venait en discussion
s'ajoute 270 amendements que le souple
le groupe cerce vient de déposer que la
Commission n'a pas examinée mais qu'elle
considère au regard des arguments que je
viens développer comme irrecevable il
reste donc
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît non mais
on ne hurle pas
le même sens mais si on les a vu la
séance la commission je dis à Commission
des a pas examiné ils sont dans la même
mouture la même veine que ceux qu'on a
examiné c'est pas du bricolage arrêtez
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
ils sont donc y recevables restent un
amendement recevable que celui du
sénateur Artano sur lequel le rapporteur
a donné un véhu favorable
donc en application de l'article 44 bis
aliné à neuf de notre règlement lire
recevabilité est admise deux droits et
sans débats lorsqu'il y a affirmé par la
commission au fond voilà
rappelle au règlement madame rossignol
se fondera tout le monde sans doute sur
le 44 bis alinéa 3 puisque ont été
déclarés irrecevables au motif que ces
amendements les sous amendements ne
s'appliqueraient pas effectivement au
texte qu'il vise l'amendement de
Monsieur Savary porte sur le même objet
que la que l'article 7 du projet de loi
premièrement deuxièmement nous avons
déposé une série d'amendements qui ont
été nous avons déposé une série
d'amendements à l'article 7 qui avait
été déclaré recevable donc ne portant
atteinte né au principe d'égalité ni
étant contradictoire à quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui et même les mêmes
amendements devenus sous amendements
positionné comme il le faut à La Linea 3
à 5 c'est-à-dire bien positionné et qui
était recevable hier sur le fond
deviennent irrecevables maintenant quand
ils sont sur l'amendement je ne
comprends pas pourquoi d'autant plus que
c'est une
assez extensive de la contradiction
alors qu'il ne s'agit que de dérogation
vous comprendrez bien que tout ceci doit
être clairement précisé dans le Sénat
aujourd'hui j'ai bien intégré le fait
que pour reprendre une formule célèbre
nous avons probablement juridiquement
tort parce que nous sommes politiquement
minoritaires pour autant pour autant le
Conseil constitutionnel lui n'est peu
sensible aux arguments de politiquement
majoritaire donc c'est la discussion
avec menée au fond sur ce que la
manœuvre de procédure que vous mettez en
place parce que c'est essentiel dans la
constitutionnalité de l'adoption de ce
amendement
monsieur Laurent un deuxième rappel au
règlement oui
oui un rappel au Règlement sur le même
article mais je veux insister sur ce que
vient de dire ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol comment on l'espace d'une
demi-heure
des amendements qui ont été déclarés
recevables par la commission après avoir
déclaré irrecevable je le rappelle mille
amendements donc c'est pas des
amendements que la Commission avait
oublié d'examiner puisqu'elle en a
déclaré il receva mille elle avait donc
regardé attentivement tous ceux qu'elle
avait déclaré recevable comment on
l'espace d'une demi-heure sans même
regarder ses amendements la Commission
peut maintenant nous dire qu'elle
déclare irrecevable ces amendements
donc il y a donc il y a il y a un pour
le mois un débat sur l'interprétation
qui est faite par la Commission de
l'article 44 bis alinéa 3 parce que
on nous invoque maintenant des motifs
d'irosavilité qui n'existait pas il y a
à peine une demi-heure sur des
amendements
identiques
donc il y a quand même un sérieux
problème et on ne voit pas comment ce
qui nous est présenté peut être
considéré comme acceptable en termes de
droit par le Sénat sauf à fouler au pied
toutes nos règles communes de travail
sérieux et responsable nous vous en
donnons acte je suis par ailleurs donc
je suis par ailleurs saisi par la
Commission saisie au fond d'une
exception des recevabilité c'est bien ça
à l'encontre de l'ensemble des sous
amendements déposés relatifs au
dérogations par profession et autres
types de catégories
en application s'il vous plaît du
dernier alinéa de l'article 44 bis c'est
moi qui préside de notre règlement la
question de le recevabilité soumise
avant leur discussion à la décision du
Sénat seul l'auteur de la demande des
recevabilité et un orateur d'opinion
concret la Commission et le gouvernement
peuvent intervenir il n'y a pas
d'explication de vote la parole est
donnée à la commission madame la
présidente des affaires sociales sur
cette exception du recevabilité un
orateur je vous donnerai pour un rappel
réglement monsieur le Président après
allez-y
oui je pense qu'elle vous a été
distribué non non elle n'a pas été
une exception dit recevabilité à
l'encontre je dis bien de sous
amendement contraire au principe
constitutionnels d'égalité en ce qu'ils
instaure des dérogations par profession
pathologique catégorique il s'agit des
sous-amendements qui viennent d'être
déposés voilà monsieur le Président le
sens de cette exception
alors d'opinion au contraire monsieur
Assouline
c'est là-dessus peut-être qu'il y a un
malentendu il y a ceux que vous avez
déclaré à la louche et en gros paquet il
recevable et là il y a ces amendements
précisément qui parlent de rupture c'est
sous amendements qui parlent
dont madame la Présidente dit que ils
sont sur les ruptures d'égalité les
mêmes amendements
n'ont pas reçu cet avis de la commission
et ont été déclarés recevables donc
cette argument de rupture d'égalité
puisque là on est sur le fond on n'est
pas sur les 1000 à la louche là et bien
sur le fond comment vous nous expliquez
que ces amendements qui étaient
recevables hier en étant examiné ne le
sont pas là est-ce qu'on peut non mais
est-ce qu'on peut avoir la réponse parce
que vous pouvez dire circuler il y a
rien à voir vous avez proposé quelque
chose de très précis
oui bien sûr ils ont jamais été déclarés
ils recevables
la Commission les a examinés et
oui ces amendements ont été examinés et
c'est le même en sous-amendement ce sont
ce sont les mêmes contenus la Commission
les avait examinés et avaient donné un
avis défavorable mais ils étaient
recevables pourquoi ils deviennent ils
receva maintenant on veut la réponse
alors j'ai compris que c'était une
opinion contraire à l'exception du
recevabilité que vous défendiez
rappel au règlement monsieur Gontard
oui merci monsieur le Président rappelle
un règlement sur l'article 44 bis à ina3
de la même manière déjà moi je me pose
la première question sur le temps
matériel et la possibilité matérielle de
pouvoir étudier alors je sais pas
combien il y avait au total de
sousaments qui ont été déposés mais
je me pose quand même les questions de
cette possibilité là parce que là on est
quand même sur le fond des amendements
ça veut dire qu'il faut quand même
analyser les amendements pour savoir sur
leur recevabilité si ça correspond
justement au texte donc je mets quand
même en doute sur la possibilité
matérielle de pouvoir faire ça surtout
qu'on a déposé ses amendements on a eu
quoi 45 minutes d'interruption de séance
on les a déposés il y a quoi il y a même
pas 20 minutes je pense que voilà je me
demande comment tout ça est possible et
puis j'ai regardé on a un certain nombre
d'amendements par rapport à ce que
Madame la rapporteur a pu dire je prends
l'abonnement
4672 sur le rachat de trimestres pour
stage il me semble qu'on est tout à fait
dans quelque chose qui en tout cas qui
qui correspond tout à fait au texte qui
n'est pas en décalage par rapport au
texte donc ça me ça me pose quand même
un problème
donc voilà et puisqu'il a dit Monsieur
Assouline de la même manière donc
j'aimerais avoir des explications assez
claires parce que sinon c'est vrai qu'on
a un certain nombre de listes
d'amendements qu'on a déjà analysé et
qui me paraissent rentrer en tout cas je
vous donne ce que vous pouvez dire la
vie du gouvernement sur l'exception du
recevabilité
merci monsieur le Président le
gouvernement sur ces questions-là sont
ramener systématiquement à la vie de la
Commission et nous faisons confiance aux
travaux de la commission donc favorable
alors je soumets au vote sur l'exception
d'y recevabilité
ceux qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
de manifestants le lama
avis contraire
adopté
nous allons donc passer
à l'examen
de l'amendement numéro
47,62 présenté par Monsieur Savary
madame Doineau les deux rapporteurs
monsieur Savary au nom de la commission
des affaires sociales
qui ensuite d'un sous amendement qui
porte le numéro 47 63
vous l'aviez présenté monsieur Savary
vous voulez le il avait été présenté oui
il a été présenté oui tout à l'heure
c'est le président l'amendement a été
présenté tout à l'heure et par contre il
doit y avoir un petit
[Musique]
une rectification
qui doit être faite
concernant
concernant un dispositif
concernant un dispositif pour 5 pierres
et miquelons pour lequel la commission
pour laquelle la Commission a demandé la
vie du gouvernement donc je demande
l'avis du Gouvernement sur cet
amendement de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
il serait peut-être bon d'entendre
monsieur Artano monsieur Artano
je suis entre vos mains Monsieur le
Président alors cette insertion de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon dans le texte
se pose plusieurs difficultés la
première c'est que le régime de retraite
à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon date d'une
loi du 17 juillet 87 qui n'est pas visée
dont l'amendement qui a été proposé donc
il y a un problème déjà de légistique et
de droit sur l'application du texte à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon la deuxième
chose c'est que j'ai obtenu après moult
insistance un engagement du gouvernement
et du ministère des Outre-mer de ne pas
toucher à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon pour
l'instant sur le recul de l'âge légal
pourquoi parce qu'il y a tout simplement
un dispositif de convergence au niveau
du trimestre et la durée de cotisation
pour Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et je
pense que le gouvernement veut se donner
du temps technique pour travailler avec
les opérateurs locaux et la Caisse de
Prévoyance sociale c'est la raison pour
laquelle effectivement le gouvernement
ne souhaite pas prendre cette décision
maintenant je vais à la disposition du
ministre du socle de l'engagement du
ministère des Outre-mer c'est pas une
lubie de ma part mais effectivement il a
de vraies difficultés juridiques au-delà
du fait que je ne saurais qu'invité le
ministre à ne pas persister dans ce
recul d'âge légal puisque je m'y oppose
fondamentalement alement mais il y a des
problèmes de droit monsieur le Président
alors monsieur le rapporteur donc je
rectifie l'amendement conformément à ce
qui a été dit par Monsieur Artano
donc monsieur Artano retire son sous
amendement et le 47 62 devient rectifié
nous sommes d'accord la vie du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
simplement faire une précision pour dire
que il y a une difficulté particulière
sur Saint-Pierre Miquelon il y en a une
aussi sur Mayotte je connais
l'implication du sénateur de Mayotte qui
est juste en face de moi tany Mohamed
Sully et nous devons continuer à
travailler pour faire en sorte que les
travaux qui sont les siens puissent
déboucher et aboutir de la manière la
plus favorable pour le système de
retraite pour le reste la vie du
Gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement rectifié
bien
alors j'ai
un sous amendement
l'amendement
toujours 47 62 pardonnez-moi qui était
présenté par Madame ponce et Monge
monsieur Gontard
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
déposer des sous amendements
nous allons procéder au vote
voilà pourquoi alors on a le droit de
déposer j'ai le droit de sous-amender un
amendement
on se voit
première signataire madame Pau c'est
Monge qui porte le numéro 311
bien il a été distribué
et il remplace la date de 68 par la date
de 69 non il n'est pas défendu donc nous
allons procéder maintenant nous avons la
vie du gouvernement et nous allons
procéder aux explications de votre
[Musique]
suspens je suspends 10 minutes
la séance est reprise madame la
Présidente
et merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente de la Commission
et après je vous donne la parole
d'autres amendements le temps pendant
l'interruption était déposée
et la commission ils sont tous dans la
même veine de ce qui est avant avec les
mêmes les mêmes
contradictions avec le sens de
l'amendement du rapporteur donc pour les
mêmes raisons suscitent les mêmes effets
ils sont également irrecevables merci
nous passons donc aux explications de
vote sur le tableau de bord de la parole
madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur le
laisser parler la Présidente je dis
quelque chose qui vous fait rire non
vous me dites
donc monsieur le Président après le
recours au 47 ans par le gouvernement
pour examiner ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative la commission des affaires
sociales a pris la décision de rejeter
tous les sous amendements que nous avons
déposé et les a examinés à une vitesse
je dois dire et claire sans tenir compte
de ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que des sous amendements
ont été donc rejetés alors que les
amendements les mêmes les mêmes qui les
mêmes amendements ont été retenus en
leur temps lors des travaux de la
commission des affaires
sociales donc j'ai une question moi cela
veut simplement dire que le Sénat ne
veut pas débattre de l'article 7 qui est
pourtant
le cœur du texte et le sujet le sujet
d'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite qui préoccupe des millions de
nos concitoyens et de nos concitoyens
comme on l'a vu aujourd'hui dans la rue
et les jours précédents et comme on le
verra encore samedi prochain donc vous
refusez le débat démocratique et
sincèrement monsieur le Président je
pense et vous me connaissez je pense que
ça ne mord pas notre institution ça
n’honore pas le Sénat et je veux vous le
dis aussi crûment que ça nous refusons
de participer à cette pantomine et nous
quittons l'hémicycle ce soir et nous
reviendrons demain
monsieur le Président Kader
que le Président je vous en prie
monsieur le Président mais monsieur et
les ministres
vous sentez que nous sommes dans une
colère froide voilà les événements sont
passés
je regrette ce qui nous arrive
collectivement mes chers collègues je
pense que la droite sénatoriale est en
train de rentrer dans une machine
infernale qui est en train de la
submerger y compris en termes d'image il
comprend un terme d'image ce qu'a dit
notre collègue les assassis sur
l'irrostabilité les amendements qui
n'ont même pas été examinés
ils n'ont pas pu être examinés
techniquement mes chers amis c'est
impossible et ils ont été déclarés
irrecevable
peut-être que vous considériez que nous
n'aurions pas de riposte potentiel après
l'utilisation de
l'amendement prioritaire porté par le
rapporteur
mais nous avons le droit de nous
exprimer essayer de défendre nos idées
vous ne voulez pas manifestement et il y
a beaucoup beaucoup
d'imperfections pour ne pas dire
de bricolage dans la gestion de notre
débat de ce soir je le regrette monsieur
le Président vous n'êtes sûrement pour
rien mais le constat il est là et les
membres de mon groupe donc ont décidé de
s'associer à la démarche qui est la
nôtre de vous laisser vous voterez
peut-être l'article 7 cette nuit et bien
nous en rendre compte devant les
Français qui ont défilé aujourd'hui mes
chers collègues nous vous laissons entre
vous
monsieur Gontard
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
d'abord vous dire quand même parce que
je vois que ça en fait rire certains
parlent de cinéma moi je trouve quand
même que le moment il est grave il est
grave il est lourd et franchement
l'image je vais le dire quand même
l'image que vous donnez
on a débattu on a débattu on a des
battues
longuement pendant trois jours on est
arrivé à cet article en cet article 7 il
n'y avait aucune raison d'interrompre ce
débat et de vouloir passer en force
comme le vous le faites et puis ensuite
on entrave ce soir notre droit
d'amendement parce que franchement on
dépose des sous-amendements c'est
impossible matériellement de pouvoir
faire ce que vous avez fait donc c'est
une entrée à vos droits d'amendement
c'est une entrave au droit parlementaire
à notre travail de parlementaire moi je
suis peiné effectivement que ça se passe
ici et que ça se passe ici au Sénat je
pense qu'on avait donné une bonne image
et que là on donne une image vous donner
une image désastreuse donc avec
l'ensemble des trois groupes
effectivement nous allons quitter
l'assemblée mais je peux vous dire que
les sénatrices et les sénateurs de nos
trois groupes ne le font pas de gaieté
de coeur franchement on avait mieux à
faire ce soir on avait mieux à faire
toute cette semaine pour contexte
effectivement d'importance un texte qui
est attendu avec des gens qui ont défilé
aujourd'hui en nombre que ça vous plaise
ou pas et que cette place au débat elle
était importante donc on va partir et on
le regrette vous ferez ce que vous
voulez cette nuit nous on reviendra
demain et j'espère qu'on pourra revenir
dans des conditions un peu plus sereine
pour pouvoir débattre et travailler
sereinement merci à tourne la présidente
et moi-même opposer une question
monsieur kaner
vite qu'on a pas eu le temps matériel
d'examiner c'est sous un manquements
nous avions pour vous dire ce sont les
amendements que
l'amendement du rapporteur de fait
faisait tomber ces amendements c'est
quand même 600 dérogations par métier
500 qui supprimaient des alinéas on
avait des amendements déposés sur un
article qui comprend 180 linéaires
autant que sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale tous les sous amendements que
vous mettez correspondent à vos
amendements vos amendements on les a
examinés on les a tous examinés on leur
a donné un avis défavorable en
commission donc quand ils arrivent c'est
pas compliqué même ce sont les mêmes
donc les mêmes qu'on a examiné donc nous
dites pas qu'on n'avait pas le temps
mais non ne dites pas qu'on n'avait pas
le temps de les examiner ce sont les
mêmes tous les mêmes sauf quelques-uns
qu'on a regrappié comme ça et d'autres
mais les autres ce sont les mêmes donc
ce sont des amendements examinés en
commission sur lequel on a donné un avis
que vous nous remettez en sous
amendement on va pas passer la nuit
après examiner des choses qu'on a
examinées donc c'est pas c'est assez
clair comme explication moi ce que je
vous dis c'est que nous la commission
elle poursuit deux objectifs c'est
contribuer à la clarté des débats les
recentrant sur les enjeux du texte et
vous savez très bien et ne faites pas
les vierges 20 ou chez vous savez très
bien que lorsque vous déposez un millier
d'amendements plus d'un millier
d'amendements sur l'article 7 en faisant
des tas de trucs comme ça vous clarifier
et vous clarifier le débat il reste à
l'issue de l'abonnement du rapporteur
plus d'une centaine d'amendements qui
seront sur le débat de fond sur le débat
de fond et nous l'aurons demain
donc je voulais vous demander si vous
mainteniez votre demande de scrutin
public sur cet amendement puisque c'est
vous qui vous aviez déposé donc je le
considère qu'il est déposé j'aurais
profité de votre présence encore avant
que votre poussiez la porte il reste 75
amendements sur cet article vous avez
dit souhaité un débat de fond de main la
Commission a souhaité à débat de fonds
sur cet article donc nous vous donnerons
rendez-vous pour le débat de fond sur
ces articles demain ce qui me semble et
la sagesse et la réponse du Sénat
j'allais dire amendement éclair sous
amendement et clair et je souhaite que
nous ayons un débat mais que nos
caricaturions pas l'attitude de notre
assembler
monsieur caoutchi voulait s'exprimer
explication de vote parce que
je vais mettre au voile amendement c'est
pour ça
sur l'amendement et sur la réponse en
réalité je le dis pour l'ensemble de mes
collègues et peut-être pour le Conseil
constitutionnel mais le Conseil le sait
les amendements peuvent être
parfaitement déclarés recevables
lorsqu'ils portent sur un article de loi
parce que et c'est la liberté des
parlementaires heureusement on a le
droit de critiquer un article de le
contredire de le modifier en revanche un
sous amendement des recevables que s'il
va dans le sens de l'amendement parce
que sinon il est en contradiction avec
l'amendement et dans ces conditions il
est irrecevable et autant les
amendements de la gauche étaient
recevables sur l'article autant ils sont
irrecevables sur un amendement
réécrivant l'article parce qu'il ne
correspondent pas au sens de l'amende
merci pour cette pédagogie en
explication de vote
je redemande le gouvernement vous savez
que nous avons rectifié l'amendement
pour intégrer Saint-Pierre et Miklo vous
restez favorable
oui monsieur le Président le
gouvernement reste favorable et pour
aller un peu plus loin même dans la
précision apportée au sénateur Danny
Mohamed Sully nous souhaitons qu'à
l'occasion de la poursuite du débat soit
bien précisé que ce qui sera voté ce
soir pour une application pour s'empire
miclon puis cette voté dans les mêmes
termes avec les mêmes applications mais
pas les mêmes références légistiques
pour le territoire de Mayotte
bien je vais pratiquer un scrutin public
sur cet abonnement
oui
explication de vote
d'une seule président j'avais demandé la
parole pour une explication de vote pour
aller dans le sens de ce que vient de
dire monsieur monsieur le ministre la
réécriture de l'article 7 a remporté les
dispositions sur Mayotte or ce sont des
dispositions spécifiques moi je suis
favorable à cet article 7 par contre
quand on vient de le préciser monsieur
le ministre dans le cadre de la navette
il va falloir ajuster les dispositions
sur Mayotte sur lesquelles l'ensemble
des parlementaires de Lille les députés
comme les sénateurs nous sommes parvenus
à un accord global pour avancer
bien nous terminons sur cette tonalité
d'accord
donc je vais procéder maintenant scrutin
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne monde à
le scrutin est clos
votant 253 exprimé 246 pour 225 contre
l'amendement de la commission est donc
adoptée en conséquence l'ensemble des
amendements à cet article tombe à
l'exception 75 d'entre eux qui seront
examinés demain puisque la Commission a
souhaité qu'il y a des pâtes font sur
ces amendements je vais donc lever la
séance prochaine séance Mercredi 8 mars
à 15h nous commencerons par des
questions d'actualité puis nous
reprenons sur ces amendements la séance
est levée